There are a couple particularly
notable types of paths and graphs.
Here, a path is just a specific route
you take in a traversal or search.
For example, you could create a path
that travels through every edge in
a graph at least once.
That path is called an Eulerian path.
Yes, it's pronounced Eulerian after
the famous mathematician Euler.
In a basic Eulerian path,
you start at one node,
traverse through all edges and
might end up at a different node.
In an Eulerian cycle, you must
traverse every edge only once and
end up at the same node
that you started with.
It turns out that not every graph is
capable of having an Eulerian path.
In this graph,
no matter where you start,
you'll get stuck on one of these
outer nodes and won't be able to
reach the other nodes without traveling
over an edge you've already seen.
There's a nice trick here.
Our good friend Euler said that graphs
can only have Eulerian cycles if
all vertices have an even degree or an
even number of edges connected to them.
Eulerian paths are a little
bit more lenient.
So it's okay for your graph to
have two nodes with an odd degree
as long as they're the start and
end of the path.
Let's look at a quick algorithm for
finding Eulerian cycles.
You can start at any vertex and
follow edges until you
return back to that vertex.
If you didn't encounter every edge,
you can start from an unseen edge
connected to a node
you've already visited.
Again, you create a path
through those unseen edges.
You can continue this
process until you've seen
every edge in the graph once.
Then you can simply add
the paths together,
combining them at the nodes
they have in common.
This algorithm is really efficient.
It takes big O of the number of edges
since it visits every edge once,
which is the best we could hope for.
A Hamiltonian path is
another type of path
that must go through every vertex once.
Similarly, a Hamiltonian cycle will
start and end with the same vertex.
Trying to decide whether
a graph has a Hamiltonian path
is a famous issue in computer science
called the Hamiltonian path problems.
We don't quite have the tools
to talk about it yet, but
we'll talk about similarly
famous problems very soon.